it's true
[Music]
can i have your attention please
[Music]
i was waiting for the right time to do
this and
i i can't think of a better time than
right now with the music playing and
all our friends around and fireworks
going off
my parents are here andrew and ellen
bernard
thank you for sharing in this joyous
moment
miss angela martin will you please join
me on stage
okay then i will come to you my flower
damn it
angela will you do me
the honor of giving me
your tiny hand in marriage
okay into the mic sweetie
i said okay actually is there a way i
could put down like a
hey hey you know you were coming back
here
oh what are you doing
oh my god what are you doing i'm
thinking about my future
i am deeply ridiculously
in love with you and above everything
else i just i
i want to be with you forever
so leslie knope wait
wait okay just i need to remember this
sure give me a second leslie
no no no hold on just i need another
second please
i need to remember every
little thing about how perfect my life
is
right now at this exact moment okay
are you good yeah okay i'm good
leslie knope william yes
marry me oh yeah okay
what are you writing about me
i'm gonna write you both up for not
working i'm gonna write you up for not
working
okay well played neither of us will
write the other one for not working
hey this is not halfway
i did the math i had to drive
montclair would have been closer so you
have to buy lunch
what are you doing i just
i can't wait oh my god
oh my god
hello jacob hames
what are you doing here why aren't you
out looking for the belt you and i both
know the belt never left the precinct i
don't know that nobody knows that i kept
thinking
how did anyone swap my key and then it
hit me they didn't
they swapped the safe one of the
handmaids i'm assuming fake charles
took my safe and then of amy deposited a
look-alike
where did you give fake charles so he'd
help you nothing in fact he gave me
something the power of financial freedom
i invested in a pyramid scheme it's no
time to go into it right now okay
so while we all tried to figure out who
had the real key fake charles
broke into the safe removed the tracker
and led terry in the whole squad on a
wild goose chase
my only question is which box is the
belt in well
good luck figuring it out because the
clock is tick tick tocking it's that one
no the dust pattern on top doesn't match
its neighbors
you see jake i'm always gonna be one
step ahead of you you've lost the
ability to surprise me
you're just plain boring again weird
take on our very loving relationship
and it's midnight so i guess i'm an
amazing human slash genius
yeah although you might want to read the
inscription on that their belt
why oh no what does it say
amy santiago will you marry me
surprise
i'm so confused i don't know what's
happening right now i'm so confused i
don't know what's happening right now
title your sex tape oh my god i'm
shaking
i'm definitely gonna cry title of your
sex tape wait
is this really happening is this part of
the heist if this is part of the heist i
will dump you so hard
no please look it's really happening
okay it's not part of the heist i
promise this is
what you are i love how beautiful you
are i love your face
and i love your butt i should have
written this down first no no it's okay
go on i love how much you pretend to
like die hard
i like the second one you don't have to
okay yeah you're
kind and you're funny and you're the
best person i know and
the best detective
also for reals i love your butt i love
yours too gross
amy santiago will you marry me
jake peralta i will marry you
i love you so much hey jerkos this
little [ __ ] escapes so that ought to
teach did you just mm-hmm
and did you say mm-hmm
let's go in here okay
hi guys this is where our love
faces its toughest test after this
it's just smooth sailing for the rest of
our lives
holly will you marry me
no marry me holly
no that guy's got more than he can
handle as it is
will you marry me no that marriage would
be a sham
will you marry me no easy no will you
marry me
no that would be hot i would pay to see
that will you marry me holly
no only one that i was kind of worried
about
oh
this is where i fell in love with you
and this is where i ask you to marry me
it started
polly flax marrying me
will you be your wife be coming
evil eyes
ugh
thank you so guys guys guys guys
we're moving to colorado all of us
yep wait what holly has to go back to
colorado
i'm going with her i'm leaving
you